Westbrook to full course dynamite
driving dunk for Russell Westbrook
that's what you really got to do make
Kevin Durant play on both ends
Westbrook is gracious
not many players and all it can do that
[Applause]
little bit smarter ball deflected by the
reed and 32 to 1728
[Applause]
the two-handed sledgehammer
[Applause]
the month bringing this crowd of the
life watching and he had guys hanging on
him I'm gonna say that was nasty washed
to a calf strain and he will add some
defensive intensity to their equation
here Thomas catches ankles broken
Westbrook flying to the rim
and drop on a crowd pleasure when I was
known weak side help at all but then
again evident tough anyway hope to see
the Russell Westbrook attacking the rim
leaders jack pull-up jumper doesn't go
rebounded by Durant five seconds four
seconds
Westbrook uncontested two-handed flush
and he did it in no time
but you still got being to stop the
basketball then disrupt it
yes you do
logical results of the steal and run out
by Westbrook de borbón Oklahoma to try
to make that sound
[Applause]
gets around the corner Gary Harris ran
away from him so once again using the
clock to their advantage
Russell Westbrook and he brings the
house down as you see a given devotion
you know what I'm gonna say banks said
it all night that's nasty
Westbrook with 30 points
get out of my way I'm bringing it home
right now because he is shooted well
and then there's Westbrook knockin a
hammer as makes whisper glowing through
the Phoenix defense rising up angry and
coming down business do you know what
I'm going to say that was nasty partner
Wow
I'd like to see that again I got
watching the game ask how's it like to
see that again sent for the season
hasn't played a whole lot he had a
couple of key
so westbrook catch them on their feet
and talked about points in the paint
step up protect the front of the rims
and west
yes
by the defender 23 for Russell Westbrook
illegal right now oh then he just sliced
through a couple of defenders that is
nuts that was a happening done two
boards through the defense turns on the
afterburners and then packs it on the
windmill he put a little basket here at
the end there you know with a little
signature like there would be no block
on this plate he's perfect in portents
Roberson with the block long spark spark
three triggers attached and scores NCAA
men's tournament action Westbrook
exploded around a packet
like there was a lot of contact on that
play
Westbrook voicing the same opinion I
mean what's his play rather she gets in
there to that party was just 2 of 11 for
the floor for just 7 points you remember
the first two games by the bucketload
first bucket of the night to the hammer
and pull of the trigger
exploding
as he turns only after burners and
factions I like it when he gets
frustrated live with that South public
Westar oil exploding
through the lane cocking the hammer and
pulling the trigger even the home crowd
here in LA is Olin and on over that one
hey you know what's amazing about that
people there was beings underneath the
basket we'll have to wait for another
possession at Westbrook turns on the
afterburners and packs it you know what
I'm going to say look that was nasty
Wow no that was pasty basket man in
transition
[Applause]
[Music]
and sticks the dagger into the Rockets
[Applause]
Westbrook put the hesitation and a
little bit of rattlesnake Jam that shot
will knock down Westbrook has three
before the Thunder
Westbrook better one five Holliday and
explode punishing the red light at the
ranked to score that one was but LeBrons
reaction was Westbrook plus a Mirza res
sends it to injured reserve Westbrook
drives and finishes there it is the
nuclear athleticism of Russell Westbrook
curry from half-court
[Applause]
and that'll end the third 20 of his 41
here in the third to try and keep them
alive
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's pretty much the exclamation point
as Westbrook off his third state unleash
the Thunder with 20 points off of New
York turnovers state in point Oklahoma
City lead
the trigger
and buttons pets fell down
[Applause]
one out of seven from beyond the arc
three four ten overall was perfect
transition
destroying the interior defense of
Sacramento and packing it on the fly
[Applause]
Adams has himself a double-double he's
called here for the foul that puts
Koufos back to the free-throw line
Oh Westbrook with the sledgehammer ami
cocked the hammer and fired the plays
oka well he parted the Red Sea and
touchy-touchy cheat on the other side
BOCES that weak side could not get there
in time better chance to win attack that
title here is good I put you on the spot
without another chance to win a title
here
[Applause]
goodness you have no chance to stop that
somebody's gotta call the Rams mama does
that that baby's hurt up there she's
home crying for let's try moving this
way through the Orlando defense
Gort Klaatu Barada nikto that rebound
Westbrook kicks it out Russell on the
rug pass Simmons past Sarge
whispering - and stuffing
to give the Thunder a 115-113 lead and
decode that ball out like it was a tick
man he just kept digging until he got it
and it took off and they didn't
[Music]
[Applause]
pulling the trigger as he runs and right
past the New York defense come on man
you got there so fast the weak side
could not get there one thing about New
York they really appreciate good
basketball school the new place it must
be it must be the week before Christmas
let's go with a little something for
your stop come on man that's wrong
Wow he wound up looked like he jumped
from Edmund hits it downtown Oklahoma
City ran kind of stole that cash away
from Raven
[Applause]
the rim is crying
[Applause]
come on man that's nasty
but what speechless but how do you do
that over a seven quarter we've seen the
160 plus games yes he was one of those
stress for
[Applause]
you gotta cool it down hard play
Westbrook elevates pants and rocks it
back at this free throw
Weston says cq1 and raise you a
sledgehammer
[Applause]
three-point shooting we tell you that
their 30th in the liquid is less he is
20 seconds or include back of my
children I mean he made it look so easy
he was slaloming between those bigs in
the paint
[Applause]
Oh choose a James Bond playback Q James
round the big payback goodness I mean
what you gonna do that far before speed
at the rest get out the way this is just
a moment number one put my thumb out and
ask if I could have a ride in that
flower and say who doesn't matter your
game
[Applause]
the Harrison no-call
want to assist away
ninety-six career triple-double
Westbrook comes the other way it felt
like there was contact Westbrook throws
it down saw the opening and took
advantage it's back up to 11
what's wrong
[Applause]
in Oklahoma City well I never said this
to the longtime plunders but at this
point the ball game for Russell
Westbrook that is nasty
Beverly Westbrook
a lot of time with the ball above the
free-throw line and the three-point
lattices that's what the Thunderer
advantage look what it leads to three
times team up to center screen by split
the defense and elevates making man he's
not giving that pop I did and what
better way to express yourself did what
he just did
back-to-back buckets for West Coast and
he punished that rim
[Applause]
I'm gonna say that's nasty gross that's
especially their clover time an emphatic
dunk with a second time all-star
with a found three-point shooters lot of
Orlando players with a zip see let's see
it parted reselect work right down the
middle and that was a blonde stir done
[Applause]
Ross on the attack
[Applause]
put the women and children because
Russell Westbrook is nasty
you